japan hat ein problem ein dilemma die
olympischen spiele sollen müssen
stattfinden weil die regierung das so
will und das olympische komitee auch
viele wollen sie aber gar nicht haben
aus angst vor corona ihr motto nein zu
den tokio olympics das wichtigste was
man jetzt machen muss ist die spiele zu
stoppen das geld und das personal zu
nehmen und es für die korona bekämpfung
einzusetzen
und dann gibt es diejenigen die sich die
spiele herbeiwünschen wir begleiten eine
für die die spiele die letzte hoffnung
sind und die es wagt es auch offen zu
sagen
kimi ist nachtclub besitzerin wir
treffen sie in ginza dem ausgehviertel
tokios das aussehen muss perfekt sein
vor allem wenn die zeiten es nicht sind
[Musik]
wenn die nur für die olympischen spiele
den notstand aufheben hätte ich
persönlich nichts dagegen wäre gut fürs
geschäft
vier nachtclubs besitzt chemie der
kimono ist ihre arbeitskleidung jeden
tag kommt sie zu ihrer haarstylistin
seit jahren schon und auch während
corona seit monaten sap mii ihre einzige
kundin frau weiß nicht wie es
weitergehen soll
nach es ist flaute jeden tag ist hier
nichts los es kommen keine kunden
es gibt doch hilfsgelder vom staat aber
das reicht vorne und hinten nicht oder
nein eine einmalige zahlung von 1600
euro
was soll ich denn damit solange der
notstand gilt müssen restaurants und
bars um 20 uhr schließen alkohol gibt es
nicht kimi kämpft wie so viele um das
wirtschaftliche überleben trotz verbots
hat sie ihren elitären nachtclub offen
gelassen
sie wird respektvoll mamas an genannt
ihre 90 mitarbeiter hoffen mit ihr auf
neue kunden mit den spielen und dem ende
des notstands um mich ich fragte mich
geht mein klub einfach so pleite oder
öffne ich ihn und dann geht er pleite
das waren meine möglichkeiten
japans wirtschaft ist von der prämie
hart getroffen
zum ersten mal seit elf jahren steigt
die arbeitslosenquote vor allem
zeitarbeiter und befristet angestellte
verlieren jobs wir schauen dorthin wo
die menschen in tokio sich normalerweise
nicht filmen lassen
seit corona leben mehr menschen auf der
straße als zuvor
wer in tokio zur tafel geht ist entweder
obdachlos oder zählt immer mehr zur
sogenannten arbeitsarmut arm trotz
arbeit steht hier jeden tag erzählt zum
heer der neuen armen
wenn ich kein geld habe dann schlaf ich
am bahnhof
ich lege mich dann an eine haltestation
hin wenn ich ein bisschen geld habe dann
schlaf ich in einem billigen hotel oder
in einem internetcafé oder in einem
guesthouse an solchen orten eben
die meisten menschen hier dürfen wir
nicht zeigen keine arbeit und keine
bleibe haben ist in der japanischen
kultur eine schande krone hat für viele
das leben am rande der gesellschaft
schlimmer gemacht doch sind die
olympischen spiele für die menschen hier
eher eine bedrohung als ein
hoffnungsschimmer
die sollten die olympischen spiele
einfach sein lassen vor allem in einer
lage wo das tägliche leben schwierig ist
und das infektionsrisiko besteht
das ist doch keine lage in der sich alle
gemeinsam freuen können vor drei wochen
noch waren bis zu 80 prozent der japaner
gegen die spiele mittlerweile sind es
noch bis zu 48 prozent
trotzdem gibt es noch immer regelmäßig
demonstrationen in dem land wo die
menschen eigentlich nicht laut werden
sie finden die olympischen spiele in
corona zeiten abzuhalten
zynisch das gesundheitssystem ist das
gegenwärtige problem
wir müssen jetzt endlich strengere
maßnahmen gegen korona ergreifen die
olympische fackel wird weiter tapfer
durchs land getragen soll hoffnung
bringen
japans dilemma mit den corona spielen
ist vor allem eine frage des geldes denn
wer die knapp 13 milliarden euro teuren
spiele ab sagt muss auch die kosten
tragen das will japan nicht und das
internationale olympische komitee will
es auch nicht
also gibt es jeden tag neue anti corona
maßnahmen seitens der regierung zur
beruhigung der bevölkerung und zuletzt
diese alle olympia gäste sollen per gps
überwacht werden
der musikuni wenn sich jemand
problematisch verhält wird das gps
beweisen was jemand getan hat
das neu gebaute olympische dorf wird
abgeschottet sein wie noch keines zuvor
das super feste olympischen spiele
sollte ursprünglich geplant 40 millionen
menschen nach japan bringen und dem land
einen aufschwung verschaffen
wirtschaftlich symbolisch jetzt kommen
gerade noch 90.000 und die sportler
sollen vor leeren rängen um medaillen
kämpfen die angst war trotzdem
bisher sind nur knapp fünf prozent der
bevölkerung geimpft dass es zu wenig das
gesundheitssystem gilt als überlastet
und jeder der wegen der spiele ins land
kommt ist für viele einer zu viel
das virus ist immer noch nicht unter
kontrolle
die menschen aus der ganzen welt kommen
nach japan hier gehen sie ein und aus
dadurch kann sich das virus doch nur
weiter ausbreiten
hier in japan und in der welt im
nachtclub von mama sun wiederum sehen
die kunden die olympischen spiele anders
pragmatisch sie bringen trotz weniger
besucher ein bisschen geld ins land
hoffentlich und zeigen dass japan es
doch geschafft hat ich persönlich finde
ja dass die spiele stattfinden können so
lange keine zuschauer eingelassen
da werden die schon einen ausgewogenen
weg für die austragung finden
nach dem dritten notstand scheint das
land müde verunsichert das dilemma von
tokio 2020 wird sie begleiten es werden
die spiele seien die irgendwo zwischen
corona und ein bisschen hoffnung
stattfinden